everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're gonna be
continuing our coverage of the 2018 st.
louis rapid and blitz tournaments in the
grand chessboard all the competitors in
the Grinch's tour are in attendance here
if you're not familiar with the format
there are nine rounds of a rapid chess
each player is twenty five minutes on
the clock each move they make they get
ten additional seconds and they get into
18 rounds of blitz
where they have five minutes on the
clock in three seconds added on for each
move that they make yesterday we saw
three rounds of chess played Fabiana
Caruana won all three of those he will
be playing Magnus Carlsen later this
year for the world championship seems to
be just cruising we're looking at a game
today from round six but up in to round
six everyone is still chasing topping on
Caruana he has eight points out of ten
the scoring is a little bit different in
this tournament usually in tournaments
when you win you get one point when you
draw you get a half a points when you
lose you get zero points in this
tournament you get two points for a win
one points for a draw and then zero
points for a loss yeah Fabiana Caruana
who has eight points out of ten coming
into this round six it will be playing
three rounds today and then three rounds
tomorrow too in the rapid section but
our competitors today what's gonna be
played by a Maxime mvl the Frenchman
outstanding player always is gonna be
going for the win that's what we
appreciate about watching him his
opponent playing the black pieces
schecky to my medida of a very very
strong player always near the top of the
ratings so most these players are near
the top of the leaderboard both of them
are chasing prabhakara wanna and knowing
that they can get points very very
quickly with so many games of chess yet
to be played both of them will be
looking for a victory
NBL starts the action with pawn to e4
pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6 and then
Bishop to c4 so we're used to seeing
that Rilo PES here with Bishop to b5 but
instead getting it started off with
Bishop to c4 black responds with Knight
to f6 getting into the 2-night defense
and then pawn to d3 I look excited
because you never know in a rapid style
format how players are gonna play I
thought we made C one of my favorite
opens the fried liver attack Knight to
g5 double attack here on this pawn on f7
really tough to defend against this in
my opinion with short time controls but
we see more of a quieter game with pawns
who d3 not trying to get out of hand
right now pawn to h6 castle on the
kingside pawn to d6 rook here to e1 and
then already out of book line is pawn to
g5 so black really going for an
aggressive line here very seldom do you
see at high level play going into a
novel line only six moves in usually the
first 10 to 12 moves are all theoretical
lots of games in the past that they can
look at and say yes I've seen this how
exactly how this works and they have
their own nuance to it but for the most
part it's all memorized this is a
brand-new line not really both sides
familiar with this territory which is
always exciting for rapid top we see
pawn to d4 I think worth considering
pawn to h3 stopping the attack of the
pawn coming down here to g4 also don't
want your opponent to just play Bishop
down here to g4 at some points but after
pawn to g5 pawn d4 and then pawn g4 so
decided to go ahead and push right here
and some of these moves you may not see
if it's in longer style but you're
always gonna be putting pressure on your
opponent and rapid style the more time
you can get them to think even if you
have a suboptimal move sometimes that's
usually the path you want to go down the
pawn takes pawn takes here on f3 and
then pawn takes on f6 want to capture
that Knight back since you did just lose
your knight it's gonna be bad if you
know you take with your Queen right here
because then just you know Knight takes
on e5 attacking the Queen why it's gonna
go down in material here you can see the
knight take the bishop Queen takes all
of a sudden white is down in material so
needs to get that material back
takes here on f6 Knight to e5 attacking
the bishop Knight here to d2 and this is
kind of interesting as far as how white
wants to defend and continue here this
Knight is attacking the bishop also
defending this pawn here on f3 could
just not even worry about this pawn over
here could retreat the bishop could play
Knight say a3 it's a little tricky if
you play Knight to d2 because yes it
defends this but also blocks a lot of
your development and it puts White's in
a tough spot black can really develop
his pieces Queen takes on f6 Bishop
coming out here depending on to h3 or g4
depending on where white is going to go
to and why it's just really defending
here blocking his own pieces but that's
exactly what white decides to do in DL
decides yeah I want to defend like this
but knowing that he needs to move his
knight at some point Queen takes on f6
and then pawn takes on f3 so why does
behind the 8-ball here he's up a little
bit in material but what he lacks is
King side safety knowing that his
opponent can start to really put a lot
of pressure on him we see rook here to
g8 check King to h1 don't want to play
King to f1 allow your opponent's to come
down here Bishop to h3 add a tempo force
now that the King to move maybe King up
here to e 2 then Bishop to d2 you can
see how bad things start to look from
White's perspective so we see King 2 H 1
and then Knight takes on c4 Knight takes
back on c4 and then Bishop down here to
h3 so putting a lot of pressure on white
and now the main threat is Bishop to g2
if white were to look at this and not
think that there's a huge threat maybe
play something like Bishop to e3 well
the game's completely lost Bishop to g2
check King comes here Bishop up here f3
not only is this a discovered attack in
the Queen is going to fall it's much
worse than that the game is going to be
over King to f1 only move possible work
down here g1 sacrifice after the King
takes Queen over here to g6
it's going to be checkmate no real way
to stop this Queen come down here g2
it's gonna be all over so white plays
the most logical move but really the
only option in my opinion as far as how
to continue and that's night to e3
stopping the bishop coming down here to
g2 black decides to go ahead and start
pushing on the King side he has a strong
attack so Shakir decides okay let's go
ahead and push could have castle on the
Queen side I think that this was a
longer game he would start to develop
more pieces but right now he thinks
pushing material is the main way to go
Bishop to a d2 and then he thinks for
four minutes in decides okay I don't
have anything else going on I'm gonna
castle on the Queen side this was his
longest thought process through the
first 15 moves of the game so my guess
is he was really trying to figure out if
he had some other attack besides just
developing here
getting his other rook involved into the
game now NBL continues Queen to e2 pawn
d5 trying to play pawn to d4 removing
this night here on e3 if you can do that
then all of a sudden black is looking
really strong with Bishop to g-tube
white recognizes this place rook to a g1
wants to alleviate the fact of having to
have the night here on e3 we do see some
exchanging on the board and then pawn
takes on e4 doesn't do as much to play
your pawn down here to d4 because the
bishops not coming to g2 anytime soon so
pawn takes pawn recaptures and then
Queen comes down here to b2 starting to
gobble up some material we are
approaching the in game so every pawn is
essential here we see the Queen take
here on h5 and then Bishop back here to
e6 important to bring the bishop back
here this pawn on f7 is critical to hold
on to and you don't want to play
anything crazy if you look at this you
may say oh there's a free bishop here on
D - that's gonna be a trap Knight to c4
that's going to fork material if the
Queen takes Knight comes down here to d2
now the bishop could come up here
all-in-all this is not going to be what
black
wants to do so instead of doing that and
following for that trap he plays Bishop
to e6 rook to g8 pawn to f6 nice little
discovered attack with the Bishop
attacking the rook rook is forced to
move comes back here to h8 then Queen up
to a d4 and this is just a tricky spot
there's so many attacking lines that
black has how does white really continue
here did think for several minutes
before he looked at this and said okay
my bishop right here is being attacked
on d2 how do I hold on to this material
it could have easily just moved his
bishop but in the end decided to go and
play Queen to a4 defending this Bishop
also attacking this pawn here on a7 if
he can somehow sneak behind enemy lines
and it's hack his opponent's Queen takes
on e4 usually it's a good idea if you
can take material put your opponent
check that's exactly what black test
here King to g1 now pawn to a6 does not
want to have to worry about that Queen
capturing and then chasing the King
around the board here and another tough
spot for white here now as Queen aim as
rook are not connected at all the bishop
in the night are back you know on the
second and third rank they really can't
get involved into the attack they're
forced to just play defense
not lose any more mitts here on the
board so how do you really continue in
this spots white plays Bishop to c3
attacking this pawn here on f6 but
unfortunately that's just not good
enough
Bishop to d5 threatening the Queen
coming down here to h1 checkmates tough
tough spot from white to be in decide to
go ahead and take with his Knights the
rook takes on d5 and now things have
just completely fallen apart well I may
look on the board that things are pretty
even black is in a dominant dominating
position right here no real way for
white to continue if we look at and say
you know he can't take the rook right
here you know the Queen could just
capture back he decides to go ahead and
take this bishop up here on a fade start
to check his opponent King to a d7 rook
here to f7 King he ate and then rook to
seven and many people may look at this
say why would he just give up a rook the
problem is the threat that black has if
you see something like Queen to c7
well now the the threat is realized look
down here to d1 Bishop down e one only
way to stop that but it's going to be
checkmate because of the Queen and rook
combo here so why it's really just
forced to throw everything he can at his
opponent just to try to stop any sort of
attack the black has and to do that you
just have started throwing material way
and that's what mvl does rook to e7 King
takes queen up here to c7 check just
forcing black to retreat some of the
material here Queen to c5 King over here
to f7 Queen to h5 eventually white runs
out of options
Queen to g6 and you can see here this is
checked forcing the Queen to exchange
White has to take care so Queen takes
King takes and then the in game a rook
is always going to dominate at Bishop I
can easily put all of his pawns on light
squares chase around all the ponds with
his King no way for white to continue so
MBL decides to go ahead and resign check
here mama da da fits the victory both of
these players after round six are tied
for second they're in a 4-way it's high
we have a check here to mama data have
we have Nakamura came back we saw him
lose in the very first round he's been
having a strong tournament since then in
VL as well as Sergei Carter yakun so all
those players are chasing Fabio and
Caruana two points behind him but
remember a win is worth two points so
they're only one win away from first
place here there are three rounds
tomorrow to determine the winner over
the rapid section then they will get
into the blitz there'll be a rapid
champion a blitz champion and then it'll
be an overall champion as well so
hopefully you guys are enjoying that the
tournament's for those have been
watching the coverage a few sites where
you can actually watch the live coverage
I try to take an interesting game each
day and then talk about all the other
rounds
of what
going on hopping on Caruana did draw his
game but still holds a a strong lead
going into the third and final day of
the rapid section so thanks again
everyone from watching a movie back
tomorrow for a game from either round 7
8 or 9 thanks for watching